[موسيقى]
ا
يا الله يا
الله يا
[موسيقى]
الله اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد محمد
رسول
الله
[موسيقى]
الساعه
ص الاستف يا
جماعه على باب المستشفى
مباشره استهداف على باب المستشفى
مباشره
مباشره على باب المستشفى في هذه
اللحظات
[موسيقى]
حزام ناري قوي جدا وعنيف فيقرب من مستشفى
ناصر يا
الله دخلت دخلت بالفعل على
النازحين الاستهداف و الاستهداف و
الاستهداف
وين احنا حاليا زي ما انتم شايفين احنا
فعلا كنا نايمين والله نايمين يا جماعه
يعني ننا فعليا صحينا من شده الانفجار كان
انفجار ضخم جدا عليف جدا يعني صحينا
ولبسنا وطلعنا نجري لانه كنا عارفين انه
السدات قريب جدا يعني بس ماتوقعنا تكون
العماره يعني الملاصقه للمستشفى تماما
يعني بتحكي العماره اللي على الشارع تماما
يعني شارع المستشفى حاليا المستشفى زي ما
انتم شايفين
يعني كيف رذاذ رذاذ البارود تاع الصاروخ
المستشفى كله تملى رذاذ البارود شايفين
كل المستشفى
البارود الوضع سيء جدا الوضع صعب
جدا حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل